the number today I like to talk to about
is is 69 and it turns out to be an
important number for this little pocket
calculator well in order to explain this
I need to tell you something about
factorial numbers I'm going to just
start off by explaining what the symbol
factorial n is where n is an integer eg
one two three four any any integer like
that well it's n with an exclamation
mark after it and it's got a special
meaning in mathematics it doesn't mean n
shout it out loud it's just got a
special symbol in mathematics now
factorial 1 is is trivial 1 is just 1
factorial is just itself but factorial 2
well that's pretty uninteresting as well
it's just 1 times 2 and that's equal to
2 and factorial 3 is equal to 1 times 2
times 3 which is equal to 6 and
factorial 4 is 1 times 2 times 3 times 4
which is equal to 24 now if we go to
factorial 5 that's about as far as I can
go without having to write things down
and work out easily in my head that's
equal to have 120 these numbers increase
quite quickly so it's fun just to work
out factorial 20 and I can do that by
continuing this process but it's much
easier to get out my pocket calculator
so let's do 20 so there's 20 going in
and now I notice to get the factorial
there it is it's X with an exclamation
mark in and that's in yellow so I've got
to press the shift key and then I press
the key 20 factorial and all ready to go
so now I put equals and this comes out
to be 2 point 4 3 - 9 0 to 0 0 8 and now
is the important bit times 10 to the 18
so this is now really quite large number
that number is much much bigger than the
number of stars in our galaxy and a bit
smaller than the number of stars in the
observable universe there are 69 if we
work out factorial 69 it turns out that
this is the largest number factorial
number that I can calculate on my little
cap pocket calculator here
d9 and then we do shift and and what do
I get for that I get one point SEM 1 1 2
2 4 5 2 4 and that's when I calculate
the stop times 10 to the 98 now you can
see we're getting quite close to this
big number of 10 to 100 here and it
turns out that that is the largest
number I can factorial number I can
compute on my calculator if I go to the
next number factorial SEM T which of
course is just factorial 69 times 70 so
I'll put in and then try to work out the
factorial what do I get so I get error
which means is the numbers become too
big for my calculator - now factorial
numbers are interesting in themselves
but for us physicists they really are
very important in statistics and in
statistical physics these things crop up
in very beautiful ways and need to all
sorts of exotic things like the
properties of electrons and even the
properties of those other sorts of
particles bosons but that's a bit of
another story